I guess I know not a lot of things are
gonna fit I'm not really sure what to
expect with this yeah I think it's just
gonna be really silly
I wouldn't size fits all hats don't even
fit all people everybody's so different
that like to be small up here big down
here I don't know
[Music]
I'm apparently going to fit this over my
head we got this there's there's just
nothing good about this for me
this isn't gonna fit everyone doesn't
fit me honestly this just makes me want
to go like this if it's okay it's not
great it's fine
my mom used to say something that was
like I'm a size two sausage and a size
one casing and that's what I feel like
right now I can't pull anything there's
nowhere to escape this is basically a
bra so short this is one size but it
doesn't stretch too much yeah I wouldn't
wear this it just doesn't fit me I could
see through it this is the perfect skirt
for work
yeah the skirts terrible I don't this I
don't know like who who would this fit
well it fits just kidding it's awful I
hate everything about it it's given me
the biggest wedgie I've ever had real
talk
this fits super well it is delightfully
comfortable it fits I think I look
pretty good I'm not a huge fan of how
short it is here just because I've like
a longer torso it fits me pretty well
but I feel like maybe if you're shorter
or like smaller it's just gonna kind of
eat you alive this is the MVP it's the
best everybody loves it
I feel like one wrong move and I could
reveal myself the back is a little bit
revealing for a workplace environment
it's not the worst thing in the world
again it's like a little bit short on me
but realistically that this is where I
mean this is where my chest is big this
may not be flattering but it should be
able to get over my body like Jersey has
one job and that's to get on everyone's
body I'm gonna do this this is this is
not happening I'm giving up with this
guy put on this dress and I was like oh
hell yeah
like I can fit in this but it's kind of
sad because I shouldn't I don't know you
know what I mean they're like making me
feel bad if I don't fit in something
that's obviously like way too small for
90% of the human race
one size doesn't fit all which pretty
much knew going into this but it's kind
of a real eye-opener when you're trying
on all these clothes on your own body
and just kind of like putting it out
there clothes shopping when you're a
little bit bigger is is hard and I feel
like this is just kind of like one step
further and that it makes people who are
actually probably quite small feel like
that there are clothing options that are
shut off to that it's a weird thing that
were as a society we're just so obsessed
with size we're so obsessed with health
in someone is how tall someone is I
never really thought about how bad it
could make me and everyone else feel you
know the goal is to celebrate all sizes
I didn't fit into it it felt like
something was wrong with my body and I
think it could definitely hurt younger
women
need to grow that grow up feeling like
they need to fit in one size
[Music]